ANASH P. OOMMEN: Hi, I'm Anash
P. Oommen with the Google
Developer Relations team.
This screencast will show you
how to get started with the
AdWords API .NET
Client Library.
The library requires Microsoft
.NET runtime version 2.0.
The library also works on
Mono version 2.4.4.
The library depends on the
System.Configuration,
System.XML, System.Web, and
System.Web.Services runtime
assemblies.
It doesn't depend on any
third party assemblies.
The first thing you need to do
is to download the library.
The best way to find it is
to go to the AdWords API
documentation at
code.google.com/apis/adwords.
From here, click on Docs, and
then on Client Libraries.
And click on .Net
Client Library.
This is the main project
page of the AdWords
API .Net client library.
On the left-bottom side of the
page are links to download the
latest version of the library.
Now click the link to
download the latest
version of the library.
Once you've downloaded the
library, extract it to the
folder of your choice.
The library distribution
contains docs, examples in C#
and VB for various API versions,
a precompiled
version of the assembly, and
solution files for various
versions of Visual Studio.
Open the AdWords.sln
in Visual Studio.
The solution consists of one
project each for C# examples,
VB examples, and OAuth.
Both C# and VB example project
consist of code examples for
all the major API versions.
OAuth code example is designed
as an ASP.NET website that
retrieves all the campaigns
from a user's account.
Before you can run the code
examples, you need to fill in
the AdWords credential in your
application's app.config or a
website's web.config.
Let's do it for
AdWords.Examples.CSharp.
Open the app.config.
We will run the code
examples against
the AdWords API Sandbox.
Details on how to use the
AdWords API Sandbox is
available at code.google.com/
apis/adwords/docs/sandbox.html
When using the Sandbox, your
client email is client_n plus
your email address, where n
can be from one to five.
Your developer token is your
Google account plus, plus,
currency code.
For example,
John.Doe@gmail.com++USD.
The email and password is your
Google account email
address/password.
You also need to change the
AdWords API server URL to
https://adwords-
sandbox.google.com.
Note that the client library
uses two different keys for
configuring the AdWords
API server URLs.
For V13 API it uses a key named
LegacyAdWordsApi.Server.
And for other questions of the
API it uses a key named
AdWordsApi.Server.
Make sure you set both keys
appropriately when making
calls to the AdWords
API Sandbox.
The Sandbox needs to be
initialized by running the Get
All Campaigns example.
You can run a code example by
setting the example name as a
command line argument for the
code examples [? port. ?]
To run the v201101 version of
Get All Campaigns, you need to
set v201101.GetAllCampaigns as
the command line argument.
Now run the code example.
The code example returns an
empty list. This is to be
expected, since the Sandbox is
initially empty and you have
to populate it with campaigns,
ad groups, et
cetera to use it.
Let's create a new campaign
by running the Add
Campaign code example.
Set the command line argument
to be 201101.AddCampaign and
run the code example.
This creates a new campaign
and displays the
campaign ID and name.
Now run the Get All
Campaigns again.
The code example now returns
the campaign you created.
Let's now build a simple AdWords
application to get a
better understanding of the
library and its use.
Our sample application is a
console application that
retrieves a list of campaigns
for the user and prints the
list to console.
Note that, though this video
shows a console project for
brevity, you can follow similar
steps to build a
Windows form application
or an ASP.NET website.
Let's start by creating a
new console application.
Now copy the left folder from
AdWords API .NET Client
Library distribution into
your projects folder.
Then add a reference to
\Google.adwords.dll in your project.
Also add reference to a
assemblies System.XML,
System.Web,
System.Configuration, and
System.Web.Services.
Now add an application
configuration
file to your project.
Now open
example/csharp/app.config from
the Adwords API .NET library
distribution and copy its
contents into your
app.config file.
In case your app.config already
have other content,
then mod its content with the
values of app.config.
Now fill your credentials
in the app.config.
Let's start developing
our application.
We will start by defining an
AdWords user object in our
main method.
AdWords user is the entry
point of the library and
allows you to create services
for making AdWords API call.
The AdWords user [? pro ?]
has two constrictors.
The first one creates an AdWords
user object with
credentials mentioned
in your app.config.
If you want to set credentials
at the runtime instead of
specifying them in an
app.config, then you can use
the overloaded AdWords
user constructor.
You can also modify a user
object after its creation by
setting appropriate
configuration parameters
through the user's
config property.
Let's add the functionality
to retrieve and
display all the campaigns.
You'll start by getting
an instance of v200101
CampaignService using
the Get Service
method of AdWords user.
This call creates a
CampaignService object
configured with the current
settings of the user object.
You can also modify an existing
service object's
configuration by modifying its
request [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
property.
Now create a selector
and set the
fields we want to retrieve.
Now call the CampaignService.get
method to
get the campaigns.
You'll get back a campaign page
object, and its entries
field hold the list
of campaigns.
You can look through them
and display their cells.
Now run our application.
As expected, the application
displays
the list of all campaigns.
AdWords API services throw
exceptions whenever something
goes wrong at its end.
Let's add some error handling
to our application.
The two most common exceptions
thrown by an AdWords API
server are AuthToken exception
and AdWords API exception.
An AdWords API exception gets
thrown whenever the AdWords
API server throws an error.
The API exception field of
AdWords API exception object
holds the underlying
API exception.
The API exception object in turn
may contain one or more
errors which need to be
handled appropriately.
An AuthToken exception gets
thrown whenever the service
fails to retrieve an auth token
using decline login API.
The details of the error can
be found in the ErrorCode
field of AuthTokenException
object.
Let's trigger these exceptions
to check our code.
To trigger an AuthToken
exception, let's set a bad
user password.
Now run the application.
As expected, our application
handles the AuthToken token
exception thrown by the server
and prints an error message.
Now let's trigger an AdWords API
exception by setting a bad
client email login.
Now run the application.
As expected, our application
handles the AdWords API
exception thrown by the server
and displays an appropriate
error message.
This concludes the getting
started video for the AdWords
API .NET Client Library.
If you have more questions, feel
free to ask them on our
forum at groups.google.co
m/group/adwords-api.